meps have taken a big step towards
making europe's highly fragmented rail
network more harmonized and efficient
it's hoped the result of the fourth
railway package approved today in blocks
by parliament's transport committee
will be a pan-european goods and
passenger network that's more open to
competition
and that becomes what they call
interoperable ending the technical and
regulatory absurdities
that stop the movement of many train
services across borders
it's also hoped the changes will lead to
the introduction of better rolling stock
which in turn could attract more people
currently only six percent of passengers
use trains
next stop the start of negotiations with
member states
it's a sobering fact that just one
percent of the proceeds of crime like
drug trafficking and counterfeiting
is frozen or seized by the authorities
the remaining 99 percent is cleaned up
and finds its way into the legal economy
why
partly because of big differences in the
way some member states tackle the
confiscation of criminal assets
today mep's on the civil liberties
committee took steps to change that
maybe some do upgrade their own laws but
many don't
we need a legislation at the level of
the eu
those who are doing fine and confiscate
very well but many don't
attention often turns to the poorest of
the poor in europe during winter
the attention is timely as the scheme to
support them for the next seven years
through a 3.5 billion euro fund is
advancing to the point where
agencies helping the poor should be able
to activate their programs from january
the first next year
agreement has now been reached with
member states and parliament's
employment and social affairs committee
next step a plenary vote expected in
february